we all know that Twitter is just a
terrible Cesspool and portal to hell
that causes us to waste all of our
precious life a terrible Vice that we
will all have to atone for at some point
and pay for in the Hereafter but on
occasion there is some real gold to be
found on Twitter
which makes me think of my friends over
at Birch gold more from them in a little
bit first though
the absolute top tweets that my
producers have pulled they say this is
the creme de La Creme the the finest
purest gold on Twitter we're gonna pick
the best one
first up I've never seen a thin person
drinking diet coke by President kofefe
himself Donald Trump especially funny
because Trump famously loves Diet Coke
and drinks it all the time but the
follow-up is even funnier the Coca-Cola
company is not happy with me that's okay
I'll still keep drinking that garbage
it's just a perfect tweet the diction is
very funny the topic is so out there but
it's the layers of irony that are here I
don't know how you can possibly beat
that one
oh wow those producers did a good job
you actually this happy birthday to this
future president there she is and the
best part is you get to just tweet it
out again every year every Hillary
Clinton's birthday I go back and retweet
that tweet it's so deeply sad it's it is
the sadness of someone throwing a party
for himself and no one comes to it her
levels of self-centeredness and and
narcissism are so intense that she
posted it the Former Future president
all right next one do you know where to
find marble conference tables I'm
looking to have a conference
not until I get the table though Trump
and Kanye are very similar people
they well they said there are similar
people they both have dragon energy
[Music]
they tweet about such strange subjects
and in a way that is so off kilter you
don't know if he means it sincerely or
if it's a dad joke or if he's in on the
joke or it's so and that's that's what
you want you want a tweeter that you
can't quite nail down it's not a top
tweet but it's a crazy Joe Biden is
trying to act like a tough guy actually
he is weak both mentally and physically
and yet he threatens me for the second
time with physical assault he doesn't
know me but he would go down fast and
hard
crying all the way don't threaten people
Joe
[Laughter]
well this one's great this Trump tweet
demonstrates a different but very
important aspect of Twitter which is you
have to talk like you're eight years old
on Twitter that's what it's for in real
life you would never go up to someone
and say the sort of things that you say
to strangers on Twitter you would never
say that to their face walk up to a
random person and say Hey you fat idiot
yeah I bet you're real dumb and ugly bye
but I love it it's and especially in
this case like on a schoolyard
okay Bernie we must demand that the
extremely wealthy pay their fair share
period
Elon I keep forgetting that you're still
alive another great tactic on Twitter
you don't respond to what the person is
saying practically speaking all Elon
Musk is saying here is hey Bernie I
don't like you he's not addressing any
argument about raising taxes on the
wealthy he's not pointing out perhaps
Bernie's hypocrisy because Bernie is
pretty wealthy himself and it's just
like hey you're old you're old I don't
like you Elon Musk is the richest man in
the world speaking to a U.S senator you
know speaking of the wealthy paying
their fair share the Biden
Administration has recently announced
its plan to hire 87 000 new IRS agents
in 2023. many of whom will be bearing
arms as they hunt for your money you
need to secure your savings in a tax
sheltered account now and Birch gold can
help you do just that Birch gold group
helps you hold gold and silver in a tax
sheltered retirement account to protect
you from big government tyranny plus
throughout history gold has always been
your best hedge against inflation a
diversified savings can protect you from
downturns in the market if you have a
401k or IRA that is underperforming
right now just text Knowles to 98 98 98
you can convert that into an IRA in
Precious Metals right now Birch gold
group has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers so text Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s just like Beyonce to 98
98 98 and Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on diversifying into gold
tax free take the necessary steps to
hedge against inflation today and
protect your hard-earned money get your
free info kit by texting nulls to 98 98
98 next week North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un just stated that the nuclear
button is on his desk at all times will
someone from his depleted and food
starved regime please inform him that I
too have a nuclear button but it is a
much bigger and more powerful one than
his and my button works this actually
might might take the cake because it was
a use of Twitter not merely to entertain
which is the main point of Twitter not
merely to waste time in Doom scroll it
actually involved Twitter in the conduct
of U.S foreign policy with a crazy
nuclear State and Trump threatened
nuclear war against this peninsula if
the leader didn't cut it out this one
actually might be my favorite along with
all the kind of random capitalization
it's really superb the reason
that Trump had the best foreign policy
of any president in my lifetime
is because of this everyone said Donald
Trump he's completely unpredictable he's
going to get us into World War Three and
they're right about the first part
they're wrong about the second part yes
he is unpredictable that's why everyone
played it real cool when Trump was in
office
because they didn't know they didn't
know on the one hand Trump was a total
Dove and he ran against the Iraq War and
he ran against Afghanistan and he ran
against all the foreign adventurism in
the Middle East then on the other hand
he takes out Iran's top general just cuz
just because he felt like it one day and
you never know which Trump are you going
to get if you're Kim Jong-un and you see
that tweet you probably think okay
there's a 95 chance Trump would never do
this this is completely insane but
there's that five percent the guys
pretty out there I love it okay next one
Kanye
I need a room
I need a room full of mirrors so I can
be surrounded by winners
what a great line not Twitter specific
but I I probably will steal that okay
next one healthy young child goes to
doctor gets pumped with massive shot of
many vaccines doesn't feel good and
changes autism many such cases love it I
love it he's calling attention to a
legitimate medical concern that the
establishment doesn't want you to talk
about
and he follows the kind of trump tweet
formula alludes to a thing in roughly a
sentence then hits you with the punch
and then has his kind of exclamation at
the end you know sad sad many such cases
really good okay next one it's not
rocket science guys they're just evil
and want to diddle kids it's a great
point I don't think that all the weird
groomer or drag queen Story Hour put the
sex teachings in the kindergarten kind
of people actively have a sexual desire
for children but some of them definitely
do well we know this because the drag
queen Story Hour organization has had
multiple child molesters show up to
dance around and sexualized clothing for
little kids wow
breaking news
man bites dogs stop the presses right I
love that it really simplifies it Ronald
Reagan said this in time for choosing
well he didn't say that because you and
I have a rendezvous with Destiny and our
opponents are evil and they just wanted
little kids no that's not what he said
but he did say there's really no such
thing as left and right ultimately it's
a difference between up and down you're
going to go up to heaven you're gonna go
down to Hell and there's a lot of Truth
to that okay one more tweet
sorry losers and haters but my IQ is one
of the highest and you all know it
please don't feel so stupid or insecure
it's not your fault I love you so give
me the greatest Twitter gold out there
it's 70 As Trump tweets
remember what they took from us remember
what Jack Dorsey and the libs took from
us when they kicked that man off the
platform it's not your fault there it is
that's the winner so if anyone disagrees
with me I'm sorry to the losers and the
haters but my IQ is one of the highest
you all know it and if you differ from
my opinion please don't feel so stupid
or insecure it's not your fault we'll
see you next time I love Twitter